[Music]
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
Christmas aye that's tight that's really
really sweet Isaac just gave you guys a
hug oh yeah yeah I got my Christmas
present
show me one s all digital Oh
[Applause]
number two one of these does you have
one of these already all right yeah
bought one nice so we can be twinsies
now and when we play yeah BAM
oh yeah yours is way cool show that mom
you have like five six remotes now or
something the whole Chan clan could play
could play together
oh these are all the presents underneath
our tree I don't think so but maybe I'm
actually in the process of wrapping
another present right now gotta bring it
down
Merry Christmas me and two we're on a
kissing ban because of this I got this
Abreva lotion and it's like a little
tiny little tube and it's 20 bucks for
thing and like you don't use it and I
should be using it
my mom's cooking this is a good
Christmas I helped I helped I did the
rice there's five minutes left on the
rice I kind of helped wash the the bok
choy
we got sample Chinese barbecue did these
plastic bags one of my favorite all-time
foods of all time all time yep so for
lunch we're having Chinese food before
dinner
we have I only get one free and then we
figured you would drink some because
you're not a big alkie and my mom would
drink some she's not a big al key and
Isis not a really big al key either I
would say I mean kind of you kind of
gets carried away a little bit what we
got yes this is oh my god Easter's Cape
Cod oysters
150 150 of these guys hard to see my
brother another bag in there serving me
shucking the oysters later today a nice
little surf and turf I said that right
right yeah it's surfing surf and turf
and then we got a lot of white claws in
there
some tonic water ginger beer gin a
little loaded a bunch of gin a lot of
gin actually yes is turning out to be a
pretty fun interesting Christmas all
right so I'm really proud of the
Christmas present I got for TIFF this
year because I always play like I'm
stupid
I got a plate like I'm a little slow to
pick up on things and it works out
really well as the husband because I get
to surprise her with things that she
doesn't think I'm picking up on I'm
excited for her bed to open it and I
tried my best with packaging it I don't
know I I used to be really good at
wrapping things up and Christmas
packaging but I don't know this year I'm
like I lost my magic touch and I'm like
how do I do this how do I fold this
about getting all crinkly and I got
frustrated and I kind of just I just
gave up after over like 10 minutes it's
just it's wrapping paper it's gonna be
torn apart anyways eventually so who
cares
right judge my my rapping style I tried
I used to be really good I was just
telling them I was like I was really
good at wrapping Christmas presents at
one point and I was like I had this
unlock and then I started doing it today
I was like I kind of forgot I thought it
would be like riding a bike and I was
like is that what it is it was a weird
shaped box and so and so it was when you
open it eventually it's just gonna be
torn shreds anyways and be balled up and
go in the trash I was like not far from
where it's gonna end up eventually so it
does the job you're judging it hard
judging you sword cuz look at these
other presents I arrived and they're so
pretty and nice they're the nice nice
one I put this a nice side up already
it's better okay
oh how about this put that in there and
then BAM there you go cover the sides
yeah it's pretty good teamwork thank you
I love you Merry Christmas
[Music]
when's the last time you think you
cooked for me cuz I don't think I've
eaten anything you made in a long long
time
years ago oh yeah we we were like
traveling right - yeah we always met up
elsewhere and not flat at our home
I miss your cooking yeah I should come
home more often there we go that's what
it is yeah
[Music]
some
also there is a kind of sugar in it
that's how you make it taste good I
don't I don't use this and I never put
sugar in I just salt ginger and garlic
and mother's touch whoa what are you
wearing ugly sweater looks good thank
you only let's get out Christmas I would
say Jimmy your chimney I'm apart this
video is your fire hot fire we're like a
regular shirt I know people like get
dressed up for Christmas Day we got very
much today
some squid to toss you some fuel do you
know this one right yeah but you know
your colors the blue
red yellow yeah that's so hot Oh
Jerry's carries hairs versus mine's
pretty bad too this is a real Christmas
non that dressing up type stuff Merry
Christmas everybody
oh yeah I'm Way more excited about our
Christmas dinner all right
it's a present time so we finished
eating and we were talking some grown-up
talk at the table and Isaac's been
waiting aboard me I would be too if I
was your age and people just talking
about some other stuff patiently we're
not complaining now okay I like like you
you weren't complaining and I really
appreciate you for being so mature about
handling all the boring parts as a kid
well you did you guys are amazing
I kind of got his main precedent true
yeah he already got his name present
over here what other things can I add to
my true but that's a pretty that's a
pretty big deal right there there's only
one present here for you
oh I like you hold it on like a Thor
yeah it's like a skateboard like a
modern-day stapler Merry Christmas I
know it does look scary
alright did we get in my helmet - he has
my Astro and we had kneepads Oh
Christmas card seriously a gift card
[Laughter]
gaming my little wise man
[Music]
ya know what now we just throw this into
the guest bathroom they were saying that
they they actually gave them a bidet
like the nice big toilet see one but we
were thinking since you guys are flying
in here we don't want to give you a big
old present then I was like oh it's like
a small tissue like the tissue this day
this will be for our guest bathroom
because our our main bidets like our
bathroom but this is perfect now we
don't have to look so this is a travel
espresso machine so do you guys travel
so much dry I like your coffee we're
like oh you know and then also something
small for you to packing your luggage
alright thank you I don't know how to
use it yet but I'll figure out
with me turn what I got the big one yeah
you didn't had no idea I was gonna get
some I know you asked me if that was for
Isaac and you kept looking at this box
when it came in I do not look at it so
I'm like leave it alone you're so nosy
any guesses
oh he keep looking yeah any guesses a
guitar acoustic this is what your old
guitar that we have in our house thank
you sir once we tune what brand is that
I don't know is one of the top sellers
so I'm like I don't know anything about
guitars like Guitar Center yeah
me and two we're on a kissing ban
because of this your turn whose is that
from Oh sleepy makeup oh nice pretty I
just put it there this is quality of
wrap this is the only one I didn't wrap
can you tell your morning you can't
talking about it I know I have been
wanting us so I'm wishing for a long
like a long time thank you for finally
getting yes mm-hmm
I know I need to learn how to use it
though please don't say your fingers did
so my fingers thank you I'm gonna take
your won't take your wrist I guess I'm
[Music]
we lounged around for a good like couple
hours I don't know and we think it's a
good time to start shucking oysters cuz
we have 150 choices of shuck and we only
have three shucker so it's gonna take
about a good couple hours to shuck the
oysters and we have I've never shucked
oysters before so it took me like 10
minutes to get my first one true
you how do you do it dad's got one is it
fun
no no whose idea was this mine
[Laughter]
slice off the top yeah boisterous
[Applause]
mmm salty
Justin's cooking Christmas dinner is
about to Minch and I don't feel so good
I deal like I'm relapsing back
oh we're putting in work today fresh and
pretty much supposed to be a holiday a
vacation yeah how are you feeling you've
been sleeping for the past hour
yeah same I feel like I'm kind of
getting sick again
[Music]
oh yeah Jess you got to join us for a
Christmas dinner
yes I'm all alone this year so fellas
out there
[Laughter]
[Music]